that is is in Sacramento hi Thaddeus how
are you I'm doing all right yeah thanks
for taking my call
sure what's up well so I've been
listening to the show is a month and a
half now and mathematically I know that
me and my wife can get out of debt in
just under a year with this er new job
she's taking she's going back to work
after about two years we had a kid but
she's not really ready to sign on to
everything we would need to do to make
that actually happen and my question is
really should I just do what I can on my
own to try to bring her on board or what
is that what is her hesitation basically
so we're living paycheck to paycheck but
not because of necessity we're just
really good at spending money that we
should have expended that's that's the
biggest ones that I'm looking at that
she's looking at things that that
vectored necessities I'm not not
necessarily company to give up part of
that to is okay I think the mistake I
think the mistake you've made is you
talked about what to do and how to do it
before you talked about why we're doing
it and the two of you need to stop and
push pause on all this budget adjustment
stuff until you talk through the two of
you why would we want to be debt-free
what would we be able to do if we were
millionaires but what do we be able to
do if we didn't have any payments and
that would be you know what are your
dreams in other words you know would you
what kind of giving what kind of
outrageous generosity would you do would
you go on that would you do some work on
the mission field would you and what
what kind of trips would you take and
what kind of car would you drive and
what would you do if you had some wealth
and because no one sacrifices because
sacrifice is fun
there's no nobility and sacrifice that's
mental illness okay you know you don't
sacrifice to get you that that's
masochism and we'll do that we're not
I'm not trying to create pain for pain
sake we're trying to create pain because
it takes us to the wind it's the reason
you sweat and and don't eat desserts so
that you aren't so you can fit in your
blue jeans you know I mean you have to
do these steps to be able to get there
you have to pay a price to win on these
things but there has to be a reason to
do that I got a guy working for me that
lost a hundred and seventy five pounds
he lost a Backstreet Boy and you know
well you know why he did it he didn't do
it so he looked better hidden let's do
it so he felt better he did it because
he was worried he was not going to be
able to see his grandchildren grow up
and with that level of obesity he was
right it was going to kill him but that
he had to have a bigger incentive than
just vanity you know what I'm saying
and so you guys that you need to stop
and talk to her about those kinds of
things and then she might be willing to
sacrifice to get to a place that she
sees not a place you see is that logical
yeah you got your typical guy and so am
i guys go about fixing stuff before we
tell people it's broken and all you're
doing is looking at it you naturally
took the progression from we're living
paycheck to paycheck doing stupid stuff
if we quit doing that we could be
wealthy and if we were wealthy we could
do x y&z she did not make that leap all
you did is go in and go hey honey we're
not going out to eat anymore you're on
coupons and quit buying all this crap
and she's like I don't like this Dave
Ramsey guy it's a cuss word in my house
that sound right that closer you could
ever imagine
quit listen that guy on the radio he's
running a cult you're going to shave
your head and drink the kool-aid well
here we're the good news is is the cult
is coming to town we're going to be
there March the first doing one of our
smart money events and I'm going to give
you two tickets to come as my guest but
you have to bring her with you okay okay
and I'll help you guys with this
dreaming idea again Rachael Cruz my
daughter and I will be doing this event
and you'll leave there she'll leave
there seeing more of what you've seen
through
radio in the meantime put talking about
all the negative things she has to do to
meet your goals start talking about the
future and what would it be like if dot
dot dot or to be like if dot dot dot and
you know honey if we had no debt no debt
at all and we could travel anywhere
where would you want to go or what is
her hot button I don't know what I mean
Sharon my wife's deals travel okay I
travel for a living
and I'm well aware that travel is only
glorious for people who don't do it but
but but but some people that's their hot
button that's what they want to do I'd
love to travel the world when I go on a
cruise in Europe I want to don't you
know I want to go scuba dive on the
Great Barrier Reef I want I don't know
what is it you want to do you know I go
on a photography safari in Africa I
don't care or Safari with a gun in
Africa I don't care what do you want to
do what is your thing if it's not travel
maybe it's something else maybe you're
you can't give and you feel constricted
on your giving because you don't have
any money and so all of those things
play into this I the reason for getting
control of your money and so start
talking about those kinds of things and
and listen to her get her talking and
listen shut up when she starts talking
about the future and what it would be
like and her eyes start to light up
again the dream starts to come alive in
her face shut up and let her talk listen
to those things because those are the
things you put on the refrigerator that
cause you to be able to win later when
you're sacrificing to get there and but
in the meantime hold on and I'll give
you a couple tickets and that will be
our Christmas present for the Sacramento
event hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]